ah all right we are recording I am gonna
try not to cough too much directly into
the mic and into your ears maybe that's
like a new form of ASMR the worst kind
ever alright guys welcome to the Evan
and Gillan podcast and now coming to you
from our new cleaned up room without
wires running across it yeah now now you
guys that are watching your the video
signal it was like going up through the
wall through our attic down through this
other wall then over tear and us yeah
it's awesome alright guys we have a good
podcast lined up for you today we are
going to be talking about YouTube verse
TV we have an very interesting talk with
jimmy joste and we also have a little
storytime segment yeah sorry I was
trying not to cough I'm surpassing it
okay yeah so a lot of you probably
already know who Jimmy dressed is mhm
it's kind of like the Godfather of like
making on YouTube he was one of the
first people to really dive in and build
up a big audience in it he has a very
unique and distinct style it's a lot of
like fast-forwarded chipmunk type sounds
and yes fingers going on where here's
this building ridiculous things used in
all of the experience that he's he's
gathered over the years and I think the
most impressive thing to me is how he
just has this vision in his head and he
just realizes it with whatever materials
are in front of him and seeing him like
think through the process even without
him saying a word it really really comes
across in this videos he does so much on
the fly oh yeah which to me that
terrifies me because I'm very much a
planner and like of course I know things
don't always go well but I have to go in
with a plan and he's very much more
freeform yeah interesting to watch him
build stuff especially like sometimes
because he doesn't talk like there's a
little bit it's almost like watching
primitive technology in a racing game
yeah it's like a guessing game and
you're like what
doing oh yeah so we we first met Jimmy
at a secretive camp
we aren't oh I mean we got our cards in
the mail no but I don't know I don't
know if it's publicized it's like an
invite-only event put on by some
companies up in Chicago and it's hosted
at the Google campus and it's it's a
really great group of people that shows
up every year a whole bunch of really
creative people from all different
industries and there are no like
schedule talk so you just like everyone
volunteers their knowledge and everyone
signs up for these talks and rooms and
it's really organic it's like a big
free-for-all
it's an unconference if you guys have
heard of that before it's like doing a
conference but in the opposite way or
something it's like an anti conference
conference and like crazy stuff happens
like one of the memories that stands out
in my mind is there is a taxidermy which
I will say I did not go to but Jimmy did
he loved it he loved it he taxidermy -
rat tiny rat and he was showing it off
yeah a little in a little to-go
container I wonder whatever happened to
that rat I don't know well let's ask him
sometime yeah but also it's like the
great thing is it was like by the time
the taxidermy class let out is probably
like 11:00 at night or midnight and
someone had ordered pizza in and then
Jimmy like did a little impromptu lesson
about how to design packaging using like
one of the pizza boxes and he was
designing packaging a little box for his
new taxidermy draft yeah it was really
cool getting to I mean we've had lots of
awesome conversations with Jimmy at this
point we've been on you know he does a
podcast with Bob form I like to make
stuff and David shooter from make
something and we've been on their
podcast a couple times yep so it was
cool having Jimmy on ours yeah and it
was you know we always see him at all
these events it's so funny it's like
recently I think we've seen our maker
friends and like like the maker family
that we're kind of becoming part of
we've seen them more than our friends
and family sometimes yeah
that's you yeah we just got back from an
event actually it's part of the reason
your voice is gone yeah sorry about that
guys I'm gonna let Kaitlyn like carry
this whole podcast
thanks yeah no we just got back from
spring make and it was interesting
because we go to a lot of conferences
and this one was interesting because it
was very hands-on like I didn't really
know what to expect I knew there I made
of my shops yeah we also we boat well
you made the knife but then I my arm is
so sore blacksmithing but we both
blacksmiths to these little like
curlicue s hooks Brett from skull and
spades
helped us with those and and it was
super cool but I will say because there
was so much going on especially in the
metal shop and by the time we were
making the knife I was like I gotta go
breathe other air but you were staying
in there cuz you're grinding the knife
and sharpening the night yeah they need
to get like a breathing mask sponsor for
next year get them up yeah but yeah so I
I think that's why your throat is worse
than my time so a little scratchy but
you are
we'll see if we make it through the
podcast no don't say that so one reason
we wanted to talk to Jimmy in particular
about TV rescue tube is he has some of
the most experience with both of anyone
we know he actually got his start in the
public sphere on TV and he's done about
like three or four TV shows now or five
he's done a lot that well the current
one is making it it's shown NBC it's
hosted by Amy Poehler and Nick Offerman
and it's like a make you're like a maker
competition show and so Jimmy's like the
shop guy on the show yeah and he just
finished filming season two and there
are apparently a lot of differences
between season 1 and season 2 and season
1 it was interesting because like he got
cut from a lot of yeah scenes and there
was like like a Jimmy fanbase outrage
the community kind of started this
hashtag where's Jimmy and they kind of
like flooded the making it social media
spheres with yeah and then the acts kind
of brought him in
or that showed the power of the YouTube
community the community that Jimmy had
and I think that that hopefully season 2
reflects that feedback cool yeah it's
gonna be super interesting to see
especially doesn't you know he'll talk
about some of the behind the scenes like
on their podcast yeah it's it's just
gonna be really interesting to see it in
real life like how it turned out versus
season one all right well without
further ado let's jump into the
interview rather ado that's something to
the interview I think you need to be
like without further ado let's jump into
the interview like you have to emphasize
the view I don't have that much energy
right now so we we recently started
doing it's it's not really vlogs but we
started doing like a series of less
formal videos we call KNK Tuesdays and
we went back and forth so much about
like do we put it on a second Channel do
we keep it on our main channel and
differentiate and I know you kept yours
on the same Channel and now that you've
been doing the rest of vlogs for a super
long time I'm curious
looking back are you glad you kept it on
the same Channel I am because I know
I've seen other youtubers like like John
highs is a good example who runs around
and has too many channels I loved his
content I never know where to find it
consistently
he's Ted videos this is where you find
this and it's and but that's not enough
yeah you can't say one thing one time
and expect everybody you got to say 150
times and that's still not enough for
everybody that listens to you to
understand to get it or even see it yeah
so I try to keep my messaging tight and
succinct where can I find you go to my
youtube channel
yeah yeah that's it I'm not gonna say
well if you want this go to that and if
you want to know about my car rides that
I do go to that channel that's the one
with the logos blue you want to know
where the logos green that I talked
about going outside
one channel the viewers will either like
everything you do yeah you know my vlogs
obviously don't get nearly as many views
as some of my build videos don't figure
it out yeah and he trying title things
succinctly so people can see it and know
what it is
yeah you know it's got every like I
assume my fans know that when there's a
number beside my name that's their
number episode of the vlog yeah so they
see the rest to 82 that's my next vlog
I'm not into the vlog so I don't need to
see that
so it's enough one one theory that we've
had that I guess you've had more time to
maybe see if this is the case but I
think that sometimes also the audience
that would would really like to build up
is the audience that would like to watch
all of our stuff and you know but but
also you know some things aren't for
some people but the people who would
unsubscribe just because you do a vlog
are those a long-term audience that you
want to have anyways well you know no I
you can't really control people's
emotions yeah you know it's it's we just
got to do what we do and the people that
really love us and accept us for
everything we do we're just grateful for
those people yes the world is very
temperamental including us we are too
you know think of the times when when
you're like I said I'm not waiting on
this line anymore at this store I'm done
I'm never coming here again yeah
oh another vlog just got to do the best
you can with what you got yeah I know I
always tell people and it's easy for me
because I got a million and a half
subscribers don't chase the views don't
teach the subscribers just be honest and
have fun yeah that's what will attract
the people that you probably really
really want yeah I do feel like we're
kind of in a transition phase a little
bit right now because and we've been in
transition since we started the channel
going like less and less tutorial and
more and more just like as entertainment
you know yeah and not really talking
about what we're doing just having fun
mom and the projects more of an excuse
but I do see that like like I feel like
if we have stuck to just strictly
tutorial videos it might have been
easier to grow because those up to a
point up to a point
because those seem to be more consistent
and now like we do throw in some wild
card videos and it seems like they don't
perform as well but the comments are
like so extremely positive on them but
so it's interesting cuz it seems like
and I don't know if you see this like
when you kind of throw in a curveball
outfall or vlogs
but like it seems like sometimes when
the views are lower the people that do
comment on those are like the true yeah
well it's funny because sometimes I'll
see a video that I would expect more
performance on and I'm a little bummed
that it didn't do better but then you
read the comments like this is the
favorite thing I need my most everything
you've ever done yes that's really the
numbers yeah that makes it a lot better
when you're like well I had so much of
this video but you got to think of
videos like days of your life yeah how'd
you get have great days and sometimes
you can have me do good days sometimes
you're gonna have really crummy days so
yeah and every video is gonna have its
own existence in this world and if
you're gonna make a lot of them some are
gonna be good by just by the yeah the
the field of odd some are going to be
good so I'm gonna be middle some are
gonna be bad those like photography just
take a lot of photos and eventually
you're gonna get something okay you know
there guys that hit it every time and
you know they have a formula that's rare
but I think if you somewhere in the
middle yeah you know or on your way to
the middle that's that's pretty good
goal I think one thing that's that's
really unique about YouTube is we get
all that feedback we get all of this
information that we can either ignore or
take with us or anything like that and
that lets us you know know what we're
doing a little bit more than TV might
you know do you see those like real-time
real-time feedback yeah cuz I used to do
that and the HGTV shows and then I had
to go to the messaging board and people
would be mean to me and then if I
commented on the messaging board I'd
look like a psychopath like I wasn't
reading him yeah could you believe what
he did when he did that I wanna be like
so you were able to kind of find
comments for TV shows like the comments
section for TV shows that were on like
the HDTV side yourself and DIY sites was
specifically for people to be mean Wow
there were people commiserating together
about how much they hated certain things
about the show at least that's what I
that's what I recall but maybe that's
because I don't know that about creators
gonna see it I think they wanted us to
see oh my god oh man no public
information it was right there you know
follow this link to the comment boards
Wow
but now
I don't know I guess there are still
comment boards but they're for us
they're right there on the other thing
yeah people know that we're engaged
yeah it is much more it's much more
acceptable like hey Jimmy what did you
use Oh what I did was this yeah I don't
know why you would day so many times I
go to block delete I want to try to
defend myself oh it's go bak delete my
comment you delete comments you think
that TV could learn some things from
YouTube yeah I think TV business is
shaking in their shoes because we're so
organic we don't spend money we make
money we spend no money we make a lot of
money
and the fan base is I'll tell you an
experience the fan base is so much more
engaged with us on TV it's almost like
it's like it's like it's like MTV's
empty calories and we're and we're like
health food it makes you just think of
the where's Jimmy hashtag on all of the
videos the power yeah it was exciting
and you know I'd like to say that I
thought of that jacket was a big part
you know to be on the show that he wrote
you ever gonna be able to show well
what's gonna be really interesting is I
wonder if they learned some lessons from
season one I don't have indices
producers or from one of the should say
segment producers yeah who said we
didn't use you enough and there's so
much good footage that we got to watch
in the Edit that we didn't get a chance
to use well I only want to use more of
that content yeah you and the shop given
lessons and yeah and they're all the
digital stuff I did with Nick was fun I
mean one thing with Nick and then the
tips videos were a lot of fun so yeah I
think they want to try to exploit that
more and which is good because that's my
comfort zone well I think another thing
whenever I see TV shows recycling TV
content to YouTube it doesn't do well
but if they do exclusive yeah extra
content that really get some traction on
YouTube and that might help the show
more than the recycle itself well it's
funny because the TV production
company's making it specifically they
shot a whole bunch of stuff and they
added them what they edited and then
that's what they had yeah we're kind of
stuck with like six things to constantly
keep showing the eight contestants they
showed over and over and over again yeah
like yeah I've had an ongoing youtube
channel with a little bit more who you
have an emphasis on trying to make fresh
content even between seasons you could
do a lot of work yeah that would be so
interesting to see a competition style
show similar to that that was on YouTube
oh yeah
and was uploading like I mean I'm sure
they couldn't do it in exact real-time
because stuff like that would take more
editing but like more real-time than TV
would be so they could do a live
feedback and adjust another thing is
let's say that it's a you know TV it
seems like they needs to be a
competition they just really want the
competition but like what if everyone
stayed on the whole time and like they
got a cumulative score that's revealed
at the end or something like that you
know people don't have to get off it's
like hey let's all hang out let's all
bill I think what we're doing is gonna
change that ultimately oh yeah I mean I
don't know how what you know I don't
know I don't have a specific example but
I guess one example is I was approached
by a television company and they said
hey isn't it we love these because they
were following through one of it they
were following along on Instagram about
one of the classes we were doing last
year this is great we really love what
you're doing what if we did a TV show
where at that you do the classes and
then at the end somebody wins yeah and I
said no it's not about that I said what
I go here's a really great idea why
don't you come and just do a
documentary-style episode about the show
and at the end all eight people on the
show or on the on the lesson plan will
need to talk about what they want yeah
yeah and then that's it yeah yeah
I didn't hear anything but I said I'm
absolutely not gonna sanction anything
when somebody loses and somebody wins
yeah because that's not about that this
is totally not about them yeah so do you
think that eventually TV might become
more of that and it's because it seems
like YouTube is getting more and more
companies involved more and more high
production content onto YouTube that's
doing pretty well do you think that
eventually they'll merge some a little
bit or do you think they're gonna stay
quite separate
I think they'll stay separate because
there's still so many archaic thought
process still involved with television
yeah the money waste on satis is crazy
yeah like we have to do this you know
like they have to build sets and
elaborate sets and that nobody really
cares yeah just do a green screen and a
tabletop but what do you think when
someone from like the YouTube world who
understands this somehow gets a position
at one of these production companies and
they become the production company to go
to to make this yeah we don't want to
move over here it's like we are just a
bunch of ants in a maze and you let
YouTube are just like oh these ants are
doing a good job décadas aren't one of
the ants yeah yeah they're not I mean
not to bad-mouth two people YouTube
because they provide a great service for
all of us but if there's anybody at
YouTube I mean maybe they you know they
understand content management I think
the real creative aspect of what comes
out of the content on YouTube is the
creators yeah well you know they you
know what's good they don't know that
boy your thumbnails I mean can you
freshen up mid rolls in because that
helps us more than it helps you I think
they like I think they have set answers
that need to be communicated to all of
us and I think they kind of have a bit
of a script and can't really go outside
of that it's like the feeling seems like
all right I mean like now like no
offense to my content man
but I don't even really need to talk to
them because I get nothing new at well
you know what you know what I think that
they should do everyone who wants to
become a Content Manager they need to
start a YouTube channel I need to make
at least one video and publish it let
and see what that's like
thumbnails and your descriptions are
great but nobody reads well so there's
content producers out there like i and
jenna Marbles is an example outside of
reality for most people but she doesn't
yeah 18 million subscribers she doesn't
need to have anything in the description
but in the description is the same in
almost every single video put a
description you got somebody has that
YouTube channel that's it yeah yeah you
know so it's like people who break the
rules oftentimes what's like there are a
lot and especially you know being
somewhere like we are here I know this
conference and people are doing classes
on best practices and things like that
and you can follow all these best
practices but at the same time that's
taking away time from what your core
thing is I say you know like Nick
Hoffman said it best he said whatever
your whatever you have made fun of in
high school that's that's what you
should that's what you should accentuate
and work on your adult that's you you
whatever makes you weird yeah is what
makes you unique yeah yeah that's what
YouTube is all of us doing our own weird
quirky things learning in time you know
at least in our category of videos
learning while we do and sharing all
learning with everybody but at the same
time being our weird crazy kooky selves
yeah yeah because also that's that's the
one thing that you have because if you
tried in like say hey this person's
doing well let's copy that what are you
gonna be you're gonna be not as the
other channel yeah I know
yeah I think it is hard to like the idea
of putting yourself out there and
putting those quirks out there on the
internet for the internet to critique
we're made for it finally in middle
schools like yeah I think it is harder
but yeah there's just so much noise out
there it's the best way to make yourself
unique because it's automatically you
because it's you yeah yeah you well one
thing you said you said that there's a
video that you might have made that you
thought was gonna go huge and it didn't
what was that video I thought my I made
videos I made a cannon on a lathe and
about a year apart of cannons that I've
made yeah and I thought those are gonna
be viral yeah I don't know maybe they
were I don't even know if they broke a
million yet but I made that padlock a
couple weeks ago that's a two million I
made the canoe 35 minutes long that's at
2 million I couldn't believe it
thank you yeah that's maybe that can and
is dangerous content suppressed by the
algorithm because so during so they can
tell what are Tannen yeah we thought
that was going to be our epic one we're
like weapons weapons do well yeah it was
like a propane can 3d printed bullets
and stuff and it was awesome the cops
like pull this out really slow motion as
like ops slow motion explosions see
through and it brings bond but it got
demonetized originally and we like you
know asked for a review and then I got
reinvent year later we got an email
saying your video has been manually
approved we had gotten like an approval
back when we submitted it yeah year
later just recently we got an email
saying that the cannon was approved even
though you've been making money on it
had been approved so we're like there's
there's weird back-end stuff going on
and we think it was cuz it we had words
like cannon and gun yeah we had gone in
there originally what was so ill-advised
like potato gun you know yeah yeah right
I just found out I have a shot it's my
third most viewed video from ten months
ago it's 11 million views of where I put
the shotgun shells down the spine of
like the butt of a rifle yeah yeah and
and in that video I shot it just at the
end two times just like not we're not
shooting anything just like you see yeah
and that video I just noticed that I was
sitting what Bobby Duke and I'm like I'm
like oh I never get to monetize that I
looked through through the workshop you
know they youtube the mobile app yeah
studio yeah studio and it's and it's
demonetized well was it was it last week
was it last week no it's now that the
the money sign is yellow yeah but it
didn't turn last week okay so there's a
thing going on on YouTube that some
people don't know about recently a
channel made a video exposing like how
shot videos with children in them have
content that might not be good and the
comments aren't great and then everyone
started tagging the brands that had ads
in front of those videos and then all of
those brands start pulling and pausing
their campaigns YouTube freaked out and
they demonetized
thousands and thousands and thousands of
videos deleted 400 channels disabled
comments on hundreds and hundreds of
videos yeah notice just recently yeah
let me see it the comments of shadow has
become it's a very very very very
divisive each other that this is a
horrible idea but also the the big
uproar from the YouTube community is
YouTube stated on Twitter that they
might D monetize videos for comments in
the videos so yeah and now people are
like oh great now now we can go attack
channels by leaving comments on them you
know you can hurt a channel by use look
at that it says negative constructive
criticism who put that hashtag on there
I didn't do that you didn't know the
funny thing is people could write
hashtag and a word in it in the past and
then YouTube added the feature of
hashtags and all these videos where they
people people put even people were doing
like joking joking hashtags now they're
actually official they're in their
videos one-year-old Wow
I thought it was less than that but yeah
yeah it does feel like sometimes there's
back-end stuff suppressing certain
videos yeah it's a moving target because
YouTube keeps on changing what is
acceptable and it's in response to the
munity yeah yeah thank you so much for
coming on to our podcast us by by the
way it's been great watching you guys
grow and you know come out of nowhere
you guys are a great example of how do I
get started just go out there and do it
let's do it let's figure it out as you
go thank you all right welcome back to
now interviews that we recorded all at
workbench con yeah that's crazy
we've tried to spread him out so it
wasn't like an overload all at once
alright so we have we have more thoughts
about TV and YouTube for those of you
who haven't listened to it we actually
did a whole podcast around our
experiences with almost having a TV show
was that like episode two it was episode
two will link to it will link to a below
but I think that now that we've grown
more on YouTube and talked to more
people who have been involved with TV
and TV and YouTube in particular we have
more thoughts and II just want to kind
of wanted to get into those right now
yes I think one of the biggest things is
you know with YouTube you you play all
the roles like for better or worse you
are the director you are the you're the
editor like you're you you you have the
creative vision everything is put
together by you and you full control
over everything yeah and it's very
cohesive you don't like have a talent
doing one thing the director wanting
another thing and then the editor is
forcing you into another like vibe or
feel or yeah anything like that and I
think one of the biggest like
similarities we've heard between so many
people's TV stories is about that lack
of control like they go into it thinking
it's gonna be one thing and then you
know either because of a
miscommunication or a contract loophole
or whatever it is ends up being totally
different but interestingly we've
actually heard positive things about
that exact same thing some people love
just like showing up doing their job and
leaving and they leave all the rest of
the decisions and editing and everything
like that up to someone else yeah that's
true we've talked to a couple of people
who have experience
like social media /youtube and TV and
that was their experience but I think
anyone would probably have a negative
experience if what you went into if it's
like what you thought going in going out
of it so maybe what it comes down to is
the people that have the good
experiences their expectations were met
yeah you know the people who have been
not as good experiences it's cuz
expectations Matt yeah so that could be
yes that's a big part of it there's none
there's a huge unknown factor because
even after you're done recording you
don't know it ends up like I mean even
for the two of us it's like okay going
behind the scenes a little bit after the
Bob Ross painting we thought that we had
just filmed a hot mess oh yeah we
thought we had we had film for hours and
we were like well like five minutes of
this is usable because when you're
filming for that long and you're not
looking at the few footage and you're
just kind of like trying to go through
and do it and in real time you know your
experience all the long gaps where
you're just working and maybe not
[ __ ] funny conversations and you're
like man this is boring like or like not
that it is boring but like this seems
like it is boring content yeah where
most of everybody else we can craft
things a little bit more and we know
that we're getting good stuff although
even like like the video that released
well the day today the day were
recording the podcast a couple days ago
in terms of it being released for
everyone listening but the ethernet
video
oh yeah going into that we thought oh
this is gonna be really rough to make a
video from this we're like how we're
gonna make this interesting you know but
because we do have that creative control
we're able to adjust things as needed
and like figure it out for ourselves
I guess switch and I guess like some of
the pressure would be taken off if you
were on a TV show cuz you know the
downside is you don't have control but
the upside is you also don't have the
responsibility yeah so if it doesn't do
well it's not your fault yeah if one of
our videos doesn't do well it's all on
us cuz we did every single part of it
yeah yeah so I definitely see the pluses
and minuses of it I think for me I'm too
much of a control freak
and I
it would be very stressful yeah
especially just starting out like if
you're starting a new season of a new
show and there's no precedent I think
that would be a little extra huge on
spun notes but like in an interesting
way - I almost see so you know looking
at youtubers TV there's a lot of pluses
and minuses and I think that there's a
lot that you know each can learn from
each other and then now that I said that
I don't think I love YouTube as it is
I'm not sure how much YouTube can learn
from TV but I think TV can learn a lot
from YouTube but one thing I see
happening more and more now and in the
future are more fully funded or more
famous people from TV or movies coming
into YouTube I mean more and more I mean
you know Will Smith came in Jack Black
Jack Black and now like Zac Efron he
started like a channel and it's like
there's one of the fastest growing
channels to like start and blow up and
everything and it's absolutely thing
because I'm pretty sure they have teams
behind all of that I mean I know so I
know Will Smith does at least yes he was
like his camera guy and his editor and
all that and he has his like crew that
he cooked travels with to make content
with and around and tell the story with
but it is really interesting seeing like
seeing celebrities from traditional
media entering into YouTube and it's
interesting cuz like on one hand I'm
like oh that's awesome they're gonna
bring their traditional media audiences
to YouTube the platform because one of
the hardest things is just getting
people to the platform mm-hmm if they're
not already going to YouTube before
entertainment and legitimizing it as a
place for entertaining content yeah and
so on one hand it's like oh that's super
awesome but on the other hand I do worry
that like if a lot of people that
already have those crazy built up
followings yeah are going in is that
gonna make it even more difficult for a
quote-unquote normal person to start and
grow channel I think a little bit I mean
it seems like it's getting harder and
harder yeah I also don't know cuz like
like when we started keep already saying
it's getting harder and harder yeah
oh it's a crowded space and you know
we've managed to you know come as far as
we've come
when also I think that like with and I
don't know if this actually makes sense
to most people but I kind of think of
like there's like different generations
of youtubers like there's the oldest
generation like jenna Marbles and like
yeah Jackson oh yeah all of that and
then there's like each generation after
and I feel like the generation in front
of us is like Chris for four-eyes you
know and it's like right before us
yeah right before I never know like
right before right after notice before
yeah when you say like in front of oh
that like newer or older generation
before us okay I have trouble with that
was like time to you if you're like oh
it's uh an hour ahead I'm like what does
that mean alright the old like one
generation older than us yeah yeah I
mean in the maker community
yeah like Kristin for and I'm like one
generation older than that is maybe like
been and one generation older than that
is like Jimmy yeah maybe a few
generations anyways thinking that like I
feel like there's a class after us cuz
we started over two years ago is like in
the next class Tony builds and like the
generation younger than us has started
and grown significantly while we've been
growing yeah so I feel like people are
still doing it we're still we're still
seeing success out there totally um but
I just worry if like a bunch of you know
if there's a huge influx of traditional
media celebrities is it gonna make it
even harder because they come in already
with an audience I think not yet I mean
if you think about the world population
and how many people there are out there
and how many people want that content I
think there's still so much I mean
that's true like oh my gosh I actually
do you think so - I'm kind of playing
devil's advocate yeah I think it's
probably for the I think there's
probably more benefits than drawbacks
because like I said the hardest thing I
think is getting that additional
audience to YouTube and if they're
brought to youtube but that's good for
everybody yeah because then they'll
start exploring the platform and finding
new people well also once there's enough
YouTube content to make an evening for
someone like again and again then that's
Ben's really gonna replace Gabby because
then you're like okay let's watch the
you know three shows that have come out
that I always watch and I always like
and that can be that evening TV yeah
especially now that like people's videos
are getting longer to like you know our
videos are on average between 10 and 20
minutes yeah and like especially on the
higher end of that that's a half hour TV
show yeah which is interesting one thing
though so um so I wonder this is like a
little bit of a turn in topic but I
wonder if YouTube you know you're just
talking about YouTube taking tips from
TV and TV tips from YouTube I feel like
I do see some parts of YouTube becoming
more sensationalized becoming more of a
production you know and not like
sometimes you know being a bigger
production that doesn't mean it's
necessarily bad there's like you know
dude perfect just like huge production
they're also super successful but it's
interesting there's and this isn't
necessarily anything but there's so many
channels now that are just like huge
productions and huge teams and it's like
insane the amount of like people and
budget and all that to put out an
episode but I think the interesting
thing too is with the YouTube algorithm
and everything it links different people
with the content that they like so if
you like that highly produced stuff you
can like stay in that circle of that
highly produced stuff but if you want to
stay within like the the circle of like
the smaller crater vibe because I think
that there is like a vibe that like the
smaller creators have where it's like
that very genuine connection and some
people go to youtube just for that
genuine connection you know yeah yeah
it's interesting to think about and it's
not that I think you can't have a
genuine connection with people if you
have a big production you know behind
your show but it definitely does have
like a more polished vibe and there's
some people who are like I really like
that like an example that I love is try
guys
my guys they have a big team there's a
lot of money and planning and
duction work that goes into every
episode I love them and I still feel
like you get that genuine yeah
connection yeah you know like that's one
of my favorite channels I think it's
like that has a lot of like especially
some episode it's like that the driving
episode but they have like huge progress
yeah like the amount of planning and
setup and testing and I had a lot of
like TV like elements mixed in with the
YouTube genuine vibe you know yeah it's
interesting to see how it's gonna
continue evolving I mean no one really
knows it's all an experiment and it's
being decided in the moment by you guys
the viewers my voice is continually
fading as this well one other thing this
is looking at the opposite side and this
isn't a new show and I have no idea
where the show is now we have only
watched a few episodes of it what was
the name of that micro show Dirty Jobs
no no Facebook TV returning the favor
yeah so we will we've only watch a
handful of episodes and like I said it's
not new but it was really interesting
because it seems like a I mean it's not
really a TV show because I think it was
like a Facebook exclusive but it was
like that same production levels that
professionally produce show but it seems
like it was taking some tips from
YouTube yeah the way they breaking the
fifth wall and being aware of like their
own I don't know yeah it was it was just
very self-aware and it like would you
know very often the production crew was
just as much of a character as Mike Rowe
was and they would say things like okay
now we're gonna montage through it and
then something that's a really big
problem is gonna come up and then we're
gonna struggle with it and then
everything's gonna be great and then
those exact things that happen but it
was very like I don't know self-aware
and the way that YouTube stuff yeah been
self-aware yeah you know um so I don't
know I can't see some things from
YouTube like making their way into TV
alright quick question for you changing
topics completely looking looking back
at our Channel one thing we talked to
Jimmy about during the interview is
first channel second Channel vlogs
mixing them together and all of that
looking back do you think that we should
have created a second channel because we
have had some interesting success
starting side channels I mean we have
Evan and Caitlin gaming we have the
podcast those are doing well well we
have a second channel we do but should
we have put our vlogs on the second
channel hmm because I think that one of
the biggest problems we had was we don't
like waste that effort and put it on a
smaller channel but also you'll never
grow the smaller channel if you don't
put that out there but like Jimmy said
if you have too many channels then it's
like where do people know where to go
you know I think okay so so just to fill
people in in case they they haven't
known of the videos we're talking about
I'm assuming you're talking about the E
and K Tuesday's good Tuesdays which we
haven't done that one recently the long
time.we a little bit ago like late last
year started a thing called E and K
Tuesdays I think we only did three and
it was basically like you know our main
videos come out Friday and we thought
Tuesdays every now and then we could put
out a more casual video and it'll be
like a thing it's more casual yeah
and you know the videos would get about
half of the normal views we are getting
which was kind of expected and they did
get generally good comments and good
feedback because the people watching
them are the people that like our bigger
fans of the channel yeah you know and it
doesn't have to be like a project-based
video but it was just a lot less people
I I still think it's good that we put
them on the main channel but I think if
I redid it I know it's tough I would
want to put more effort into them oh
yeah thing is because we're like Oh 13 K
Tuesdays we it's not that we like didn't
put effort into them but um we didn't
put as much time we didn't put as much
time as we would a normal video I mean
I'm not really sure sure exactly what I
would change specifically but I don't
think putting them on the second channel
makes sense I think they do well I have
a very interesting thought so yeah I'm
really glad that we did the evidence
Kaelyn Tuesdays though because we I
think we learned a lot we realized that
we can make entertaining content from
the two of us just hanging out and
everything and
think that as we've continued evolve our
content in new ways and realize that
like one of the main things is that
we're bringing to the table is just
entertaining content people pick up
little things here and there we've been
able to kind of marry some of the
casualness of the evident Kaitlyn
Tuesday with our main contents there
kind of merge and more like I think the
content we're putting out now is a mix
of that evidence Kaitlyn Tuesday and the
more project-based videos that we did
when we started maybe that's why we
haven't done or like felt the need to do
more evident Kaitlyn show because like
we have made the main project videos a
little bit more casual yeah yeah but I
think like with a second channel like I
think with the podcast in gaming 100%
makes sense to have it on a different
channel because it's a totally different
topic different format different
everything it almost feels like the
second channel is just a place for less
good main channel content or less
finished main channel type content yeah
and it's like every now and then I think
it makes sense like when we did the
April Fool's video you know like I
wanted to share it but I wasn't sure if
it made sense on the main channel yeah
yeah yeah
like I didn't want people to go into it
thinking it was an actual project video
and then being disappointed yeah you
know but for the inkay Tuesday's or
similar type content I would rather like
make it good enough to be on the main
channel or just not do it
yeah so I'm still glad that we kept it
on the main channel I think I don't know
what's gonna happen on the second
channel it's like the neglected like
fourth child that we forget about just
like you were like do you regret not
starting a second chick yeah I forgot
that we have a second channel we think
it's just like neglected but yeah it is
interesting thing about yeah okay so now
I'm gonna change the topic what's that
so after doing the infomercial for the
ethernet video it reminded me of a story
that I wanted to tell okay do tell Oh
does this mean it's story time time
that was the jingle that was the jingle
that's not that the story time jingle
now okay this infomercial is not my
first adventure into bad commercials hmm
so when I was in fifth grade I was in a
drama class and it was I had one of my
most embarrassing moments in nine lives
all right I shouldn't I shouldn't jump
that so we had to come up with a made-up
commercial that we would perform in
front of the class and I I don't
remember the criteria for like picking
the subject matter I think it had to be
a real product I don't know but I picked
9lives cat food because I've always been
a cat lady at heart and so I worked with
my dad to come up with something because
like I had no idea what to write for
this and like being funny was hard I was
a very quiet kid you know I wasn't like
super uh you know oh my god blanking
extroverted I can't why do you say
exothermic reaction exothermic where's
the heart baby words are hard okay I
wasn't super extroverted and so and my
dad's like you know pretty funny guy
would you no longer think anymore
well I had doubts after this experience
I wrote up this little commercial I
practiced it I'm gonna try my best to
rehearse it now yes do do your 14 year
old self oh okay so picture like It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia kitten
mittens type vibe so I I had had some
beanie babies so I had a dog beanie baby
and a cat beanie baby and a can of
9lives cat food you're just presenting
in front of your entire learning in
front of my class that brought my props
I was prepared and it was like is is
your cat tearing up the furniture is
your dog chewing on your shoes and then
I threw in some random stuff and it was
like is your cat oh god I can t remember
but it was like you know like when
you're trying to be funny and you just
think of random thing
you're like that doesn't make anything
look like early internet humor yes like
early early YouTube humor does your cat
look like it just ate a surfboard you
know you think of like random stuff and
put together and had a few more things
like that that just kept getting more
and more ridiculous with a cat and the
dog and then it was like well why don't
you put on your glasses and I put on my
glasses to demonstrate and stop feeding
them and then I looked what was actually
in my hand and I said soap because I was
holding a bar of soap and start feeding
them nine lives cat food then your pets
can also be normal and then the dog
meowed and I went yeah I'm gonna be
eating baby dog and then I said well
almost normal and by this point I just
you're so committed I was so committed
but like oh my jokes were falling flat
there's blueberries there's no there's
no like chuckles don't know chuckles
those blank faces in the audience my
whole class is staring at me and I just
remember when I got to the part that
like well almost normal I was like
trying not to break down have you
practiced in front of them and he
thought it was pretty hilarious but he
encouraged my terrible humor thinking
like all that random stuff was funny and
so I had practice a bunch of prizes I
came back and I was I was like I thought
this was gonna be funny
it flopped me astray let me astray but I
feel like now I was able to put like
filter all of that good energy you know
you Kailyn you were just you were to the
head of your time that's ahead of my
time that was pre YouTube man that was
like a good like 10 years before I would
have been doing great great yeah like I
could see a viral video like that
happening it's like some dad filming his
daughter like saying like well put on
your glasses and stop feeding your cat
soap and start feeding them 9lives cat
food
yeah no it was mmm it was very
traumatized traumatising was one of my
most embarrassing moments hopefully your
dad traumatizes you in the Bears disease
all the time all the time as I just love
the the story of when y'all were out to
eat somewhere and he was making a
complete mess on his side of the table
with like his side
we it was at an Italian restaurant and
you know at some Italian places they
bring out the bread and there's like
olive oil to dip it in and so at this
place there was a little dish and you
would pour your own olive oil and
vinegar and my dad has this flair
whenever he does anything in the kitchen
he's cooks flair I'm like if you're
watching if you're not watching the
video I'm flicking my wrist of violently
yeah and so he's it was me and dad of
the restaurant and he was like putting
the olive oil and vinegar into the
little dish and with the balsamic
vinegar he does his flower thing
splashes it all over the waters all over
on my side of the table because I'm
sitting across from him and there were
like people from my school working at
the restaurant this isn't high school ha
ha ha
and like the guy who was our waiter I
recognized him from our school he was
like a couple grades ahead of me but I
recognized him and I was like oh my god
and he comes and my dad calls him over
after he'd like does his little flair
balsamic shake and it goes all over
myself Abel any goes I'm sorry can we
get a new tablecloth my daughter's a pig
you never went out to the earth again no
that's someone else to defend me no but
you know another story that he just told
me that I blocked out so I'm never told
you the story Wow
I was at the mall shopping with him and
I don't remember what we were shopping
for I didn't go in many shopping trips
with dad cause he would notoriously like
put a timer on and be like okay you have
this many minutes and that would give me
horrible anxiety okay
Kaelyn like you know she's very I like
to take my time and be sure about my
decisions it's spending money you need
how to make sure you're spending it
right yeah I had to make sure I was
spending out right and so um so anyways
we were leaving the store and we were
we're in like a department store and we
were walking by the dressing rooms
and I'm telling this this is him telling
me this story I have literally no memory
of this yeah um I mean maybe some vague
flashbacks nobody told me but Padano so
walking by the dressing rooms and he
goes oh Caitlin hold on one sec mmm and
he runs he's like wait for me for a sec
so I'm waiting outside the dressing
rooms he runs in and I'm like what is he
doing
[Laughter]
you didn't acknowledge that you were the
Caitlin that he was asking I probably
just like no I probably do not I do not
know this person goodbye dad had like
top-level embarrassing skills he was a
troll yeah hey dad my dad is I don't
really remember too many embarrassing
stories maybe your parents didn't go out
of their way to embarrass you or you
know what it probably is I have a
horrible memory I should ask my parents
for some embarrassing stories and then I
can tell them in the podcast where my
voice is there yeah yeah that's why I
took on the story thank you for caring
the podcast um but I think so that we
can we can start resting your voice I
think we could wrap up and do our thing
up the weight thing of the week
we have a music for that now - I think I
just played it
alright so my thing of the week is
Soylent if you guys haven't heard of it
before it's a meal replacement and all
that Katelyn tell you the rest okay
I'll be honest I still have like a rant
like a negative connotation of the word
because of Soylent Green yeah yeah it's
not it's not an appealing name or
concept for some reason no it's not just
like an engineered vitamin-mineral and
everything supplement yeah it's
basically like you can get it and drink
far more in powder form and it's like a
meal replacement kind of thing um but
it's not like protein or anything it's
meant to take a protein shake everything
that you need yeah it's got like a lot
of vitamins and minerals and it's very
healthy for you and this enough and we
sometimes have a hard time cooking for
ourselves you know especially like if
we're mid filming if we want to cook
here we want to be good if we want to
eat out we want to be good but sometimes
we just need to eat something now with
low effort yeah and like you can only
have ramen so many times before you're
like okay I'm in my early 30s or cereal
and so we like we're trying to find
something I think you're the one that
like found it as an option and it's
funny because we've talked to a few
other content creators and like oh yeah
yeah well it's really popular in like
Silicon Valley in places where you just
work all the time I guess is very
appealing to content creators because we
just work all the time yeah but it is
nice cuz like it's not like a protein
shake it doesn't have that same weird
aftertaste and it doesn't feel like
you're like protein shakes I think are
good if you're working out yeah you know
but like they serve a purpose yeah but
our purpose is not like to supplement a
workout it's to replace breakfast or
lunch no sorry this sounds so much like
a commercial it's just like I'm not
sponsored I'm just pretty excited about
it because it's in addition to our life
that simplifies things and that's what
we're all about well so okay this is
what we found we like the most so you
get the Chuck they're like cacao one
fancy chocolate
kakaw and you we make smoothies with it
so we'll put frozen bananas and peanut
butter and the cat one oh my god is like
a dessert is making it slightly more
unhealthy but it's so delicious vanilla
one but vanilla
straight up yeah straight up it tastes
kind of like coffee yeah and there is a
coffee one which we haven't trained Wow
now I want to have that right now - okay
and so my thing of the week and I feel
like I've talked about this in person -
a lot of people but I don't think I've
mentioned it on the podcast so you all
probably heard me mentioned before the
bone Appetit youtube channel because
i've talked about it's a live with Brad
but I also love Claire on the bone
Appetit YouTube channel is awesome
Claire
she is a gourmet pastry chef I mean it's
her specialty and there's a series on
the channel and you may have seen these
pop-up and your recommended where she
takes some sort of like junk food and
remakes it gourmet style and it's
hilarious because there's like it's like
a formula that can be repeated over and
over and it doesn't get old because
there's always challenges like it's I
don't know it's just like really funny
to see her get super frustrated and try
to figure out things but you're also
rooting for her to get it all so there's
a great story arc built into that yeah
challenge yeah I mean it's also funny
cuz like she and Brad always antagonize
each other yeah and in the bone Appetit
videos everyone is in the Test Kitchen
so people make little guest appearances
appearances and they're each other's
videos um her latest one was remaking
peeps oh yeah this was a really good one
I'm trying to think of what my favorite
one was I don't know there's Oreos was
pretty good Oreos was good um I really
like Cheetos also oh yeah Cheetos was
good um but yeah so it's it's really
entertaining and I think one thing that
I get out of her videos especially as we
you know have been trying to figure out
our style is that the meat of the videos
is her talking to the camera like kind
of testing things in the moment and
talking about what's going wrong and
what she's gonna try to do next and the
part where she's actually doing it is
sped through it's like really
upbeat music boom boom yeah boom boom
here she's she's whisking some sugar
here she's like blending this here she's
rolling out that and then it goes back
to you know real time her like talking
to the camera again and it made me
realize like that the doing the making
isn't doesn't have to be what the video
is about for her it's about like the
struggle and you get most of that while
you're talking to her
yeah not while she's like busy whisking
stuff and cut and stuff you know that
part's gonna set through something I
know it's it's interesting I love her
channel will not hurt channel I love her
videos on bone Appetit so we'll link to
her most recent one yeah I like the
playlist or something also guys thank
you for sticking with us through this
podcast as I struggle through it we're
probably gonna have a lot of cuts cuz
there's a lot of coughing and through
hopefully it won't be noticeable to you
guys yeah hopefully you guys will still
give us those five star reviews on the
iTunes Store if you want to make Evan
feel better
hey I stuck with us I made this happen
despite being deathly sick oh my
fainting couch you're using those
infomercial acting skills Oh racking up
those medical bills so if you could also
help us out by sharing this with a
friend a family member or an enemy who
knows yeah maybe your enemy will become
your friend yeah yeah like hey I know
we're enemies but you share that
wonderful podcast with me and now I want
to be a friend that's most likely the
thing that's gonna happen I think it's a
very uplifting story and I think we
should all do more of that in our lives
see you next time bye
[Music]